we're here at the premiere of Netflix's
true in the rainbow kingdom Kelly
Rowland came out to support with her son
Titan and of course dished on Beyonce's
twins have you met them yet
of course adorable despot absolutely you
couldn't expect anything less I have to
tell you we love the photos of you jay-z
and Beyonce get in the gym the other day
tell us who goes the hardest in the gym
what is a workout with you three lights
everybody goes hard it's a whole bunch
of us that go and workout and we have a
really good time we go to Angela Davis
is so psycho yeah she's incredible
so she pushes you and SoulCycle is just
this really incredible mental workout
that is just awesome but Angela Davis
look she is the master and there is no
one like her he saw the adorable photos
of you at Serena Williams baby shower
what parenting advice have you given her
as she approaches she's going to be an
amazing mother really all hands down
she's going to be an amazing mother I'm
so excited for her it was just it's
natural for her and this baby is going
to probably run the world with that gene
pool
absolutely absolutely it's more so than
the mental of it all you know what I
mean like it takes a hell of a woman to
be with child and play and winning the
open so incredible incredible Titan is
approaching his third birthday he is
fluent in Spanish I'd like for him to
start French he's showing more of your
personality or your husband's personnel
actually it's a very it's a really
interesting fraud I don't know how he's
able to do that
but yeah he's got the musical
inclination very musical very music oh
my god the Destiny's children perhaps in
the works I don't know about that but